[Music]
foreign
end
you seek that which would bestow upon
you the right to rule
the quest to reclaim a Homeland
and slay a dragon
do not think I won't kill you
when did we allow evil to become
stronger than us it is not our fight
this is a fight
it's under there that's happened
such as the nature of evil
in time all thou things come forward
[Music]
you'll destroy us all
God
was that an earthquake that my land
was a dragon
[Music]
foreign
thank you
on your knees
okay chop it off chop it off let's do it
oh we got him now
you know what I'm thinking they're
probably sharper stairs somewhere else
we're thieves but we help the wrong
person steal the wrong thing and unleash
the greatest evil the world has ever
known
the red Wizards created an army of the
undead
sounds lovely quite the opposite I know
I was being ironic I find irony as a
blade because he who wields it most
especially you're not a lot of fun are
you how are we gonna pull this off we're
gonna need a team
the orifice
I'll go lost
she missed
no that's not good
I want you sick of failing we could die
it's worse things than dying
I lost everything that ever mattered to
me and if we quit now that's for nothing
I don't want to see you die which is why
I'm Gonna Leave the Room
the bridge is protected by an ancient
trap we must not trigger the mechanism
I may have triggered the mechanism
so
sorry
this is my home
we are fishing hunting and a Charming
view of the sunsets the only problems
are the pests
you see most places have mice or
mosquitoes we have
thank you dragons
fighting dragons is everything around
here my name's hiccup
I've always wanted to be a great Viking
oh come on let me out I need to make my
mark you've got left the homo you can't
swing an ax you can't even throw one of
these but this will throw it for me
oh I hit it yes I hit it
I have brought down this Mighty Beast
foreign
nice dragon okay
[Music]
no no no no
links
[Music]
it's okay Astrid toothless you're so
busted we're dead
be the refinished then but they'll
finish us everything we know about them
is wrong
you're crazy I like that let me show you
gently
there's you for nothing you useless
reptile who works How to Train Your
Dragon in three days
I'd like to make an announcement
Hogwarts Castle in order to be your home
this year but home to some very special
guests as well
and now a lovely ladies of bobans
[Music]
I was just wondering if maybe he wanted
to go to the ball with me Mr Weasley
place your right hand on my waist where
[Music]
is that Hermione Granger with Victor
Crump your fraternizing with the Enemy
the enemy
hogwash has been chosen to host a
legendary event the tray wizard
tournament
and now a champion selection
Victor crap
identical Cedric Diggory
Harry Potter how did you do it I didn't
put my name in that cup I don't want
eternal glory
it's not our mood
the killing curse only one person is
known to have survived definitely
sitting in this room people die in this
tournament
the devils are inside the walls
so he's coming closer I can feel it the
dark Lords arise again is it Voldemort
[Music]
everything's going to change now isn't
it
[Music]
foreign
is anyone there
I'm trying to reach
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
ERS we believe that these Titans are
just the tip of the iceberg
[Applause]
the Titans are here to protect us
[Music]
which of these Titans are here to
threaten us
foreign
so you'd want to make Godzilla our pet
no
we would be his
you're sure he's gonna be okay
they're everywhere
battling for dominance
a rival Alpha to Godzilla
you gotta be kidding
[Music]
throughout my life
the ten Rings gave our family power
if you wanted them to be yours one day
you have to show me you are strong
enough to carry them
you are a product of all who came before
you
the legacy of your family
your mother
whether you like it or not
you are also your father
I told my man they wouldn't be able to
kill you if they try
glad I was right
he's just a criminal who murders people
be careful how you speak to me boy
I thought I could change my name
starting
you could never
Escape his shadow
[Music]
can't run from your past
is this what you wanted
uh
you got this
thank you
[Music]
I was out here at the Eastern Pad
but that's 50 miles east from where we
found him
hey
do you know where your parents are your
family
my guess he was on a picnic or a camping
trip he wandered off and got himself
lost
I've been out in the woods doing things
his own way it sounded like a boy after
your own all right
how long has he been out there six years
nobody can survive in that forest for
six years
at least not alone
you'll see I have Elliot
[Music]
who's Elliot
you need to get back to him he gets
scared when I'm gone is Elliot a person
no he looks like a dragon what's a
dragon
that's a dragon
you don't have to run anymore Pete you
can stay with us
this thing is dangerous
Elliot you have no idea what this thing
is capable of
[Music]
very brave did you know that you might
be the best boy I've ever met
attention all units for eastbound on
millhaven Road in pursuit of a dragon
it's a dragon you can't see Dragon over
the radio
every day further moves closer to Modern
do you know that what does your heart
tell you
come roster
[Music]
it is
shall be king become Who You Are Born to
Be
[Music]
I see in your eyes the same fear that
would take the heart of me
a day may come on the courage of men
fails
[Music]
when we forsake our friends and break
all bonds of Fellowship but it is not
this day
with me
this day we fight
[Applause]
[Music]
they will follow you into battle you
have given us hope
there is nothing for you here only death
[Music]
we cannot achieve Victory through
strength of arms
not for ourselves but we can give Frodo
his chance
[Music]
alright guys remember what we're looking
for and don't trust anyone
hey baby where are your parents
[Music]
impressive we could use someone like you
let's catch you up my name is Raya our
lands have been at War for as long as we
can remember our people never see eye to
eye
my daughter I believe our people can
come together again but someone has to
take the first step now in order to
restore peace we must find The Last
Dragon I wish to join this Fellowship of
particularly
let's go
we'll have to watch our backs
we're not the only ones looking
tears are searching please let this be
it
who said that we really need your help
yeah I'm gonna be real with you I'm not
like the best dragon have you ever done
like a group project but there's like
that one kid who didn't pitch in as much
but still ended up with the same grave
uh we're doomed
the dragon they're coming with me hmm my
sword here says we're not
the world's broken
you can't trust anyone
maybe it's broken because you don't
trust anyone
the first step
foreign
so much faster in theaters or order it
on Disney plus with Premiere access
March 5th
[Music]
you have returned for a reason
far
and now your journey lies Beyond
passed away King queen of Narnia
repeating your majesties
[Music]
Christmas there is the source of your
troubles enemies will unite it seeks to
corrupt all goodness steal the light
from this world and the only power to
stop them that sword you carry it was
belated as lands table only then can
their true power be released dies Beyond
Narnia itself aslan's country do you
really believe there's such a place we
have nothing if not belief from C.S
Lewis's epic Masterpiece
here comes the motion picture event
of the holiday season
Travelers of Narnia I am your guide you
are most beautiful
distraction for you I can change forms
no
[Music]
now is the time to be strong never get
in
The Chronicles of Narnia The Voyage of
the Dawn Treader
in digital 3D directed by Michael
lapdead
I'm looking for someone who assault for
you a half-breed banished from our land
[Music]
foreign
those who enslaved you have taken over
our land Mountain
s
we believe you are the only one who can
help us
their army is infinite we are 47. if
if there's no coming back
the enemy will be watching
I know what you are you have no idea
I'm not afraid of you
[Music]
your life belongs to us then take it if
you can
come on
Princess where are you
it's very spooky in here I'm playing no
games
well at least we know where the princess
is but where's it
DreamWorks Pictures invites you to a
land of fairy tales hey oh no no no no
dead girl off the tablet the bed's taken
what where an unlikely hero you
definitely need some Tic Tacs or
something cause your breath stinks
rescues a fair princess you didn't play
the dragon it's on my to-do list from a
nasty villain
with the help of his trusty companion
this is gonna be fun we can see him late
swapping manly stories in the morning
I'm making waffles this summer
one name spells action
you're not exactly what I expected one
name spells Adventure how about here
before this is over I'm gonna need a
whole lot of serious therapy
one name Don't Look Down trick I'm
looking down spells Romance
there's no way to behave in front of a
princess
she's as nasty as you are come on
there's an arrow in your butt
oh and that name is Shrek Shrek thank
you very much I'm here till Thursday
Mike Myers Eddie Murphy Cameron Diaz
John Lithgow you love this woman don't
you yes you want to hold her yes please
[Music]
Shrek wow wow let's do that again no no
there is a place like no place on Earth
some
to survive it you need to be as mad as a
Hatter which luckily
I am Alice it's you
you're back Alice Alice Alice you're
absolutely Alice I know you anywhere
Wonderland
the Red Queen 's taken over all of
help us meet the world right again
to pick here
I love a warm Pig belly for my aching
feet it's not bad
[Music]
we have our champion
this is impossible
and if you believe it is
[Music]
well
I shall bestow a gift on the child
before the sun sets on her 16th birthday
she will fall into a sleep like death
curious little bestie
bring her to me
foreign
don't be afraid I am not afraid then
come out
then you'll be afraid
all the other fairies fly and why don't
you I had wings once they were strong
but they were stolen from me there is
evil in this world
and revenge
laughs
bring me her head
I call on those who live in the shadows
is it true
you're Maleficent
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
Captain do you have any idea what those
markers are they look pretty ancient
Trek's in here it's definitely bravo
team they don't just disappear
ah where the hell are we that lightning
and hit those markers and it took us
somewhere
guys
so what are we like Guardians of the
Galaxy now
oh that's six
yeah Bros
[Music]
[Applause]
this is officially above my pay grade
I don't care what those creatures are
we destroyed them and close the Gateway
I'm getting us all home
thank you
foreign
thousands of miles
search of a weapon more powerful than
we've ever known
[Music]
why are you here we came to trade you
lie you are thieves
[Music]
what was that there are many things you
have not seen
the Great Wall
it's the only barrier
keeping the world safe
yeah
of God
[Music]
what is it they want
to feed
they've trained all their lives for this
war
let me fight with you
[Music]
this is where you choose to die good
luck with that
stay in flight
you think they see you as some kind of
hero
I fought for greed
and gods
this is the first war I've seen
fighting
foreign